step right up and behold one of the
unexplained mysteries of the universe is
he man
or beast
you're in luck because tonight
you will see hip feed
nightmare alley is a look and a very
specific strata of the underbelly of
america
it is the flip side of the american
dream
it's a nightmare
guillermo's films always have an
otherworldly quality that it will allow
people also to be told a wonderful story
about themselves and the world in which
they live guillermo's ability to mix
genres and still have it rooted in a
reality that's what i like about his
work
are you in contact with the beyond
well we've had our share of snake
charmers in the past
we deal with them
[Music]
this movie is a testament to guillermo's
creativity how his mind is constantly
embroidering
moments and building on what he sees
mr carla
i love noir as a mood as an emotion as a
sentiment i tried to study the language
of the period
and action
i want to shoot bradley cooper as stan
and design everything around him
as you would with a movie star in the
1930s everything will be carefully
presented to make him look as powerful
as a presence would in classic cinema
an electra complex isn't it i wouldn't
know about that but you're not as hard
to read as you think lady
gabe blanchett we are going to present
her as one of the grand dams of that
period of cinema i give you a little
information and you tell me the truth
there's something about guillermo's
ability to visually unearth
monstrosities that make this an amazing
addition to his body of work i want this
to be the modern equivalent
of the movies that people complain they
don't do anymore
it's a movie that celebrates cinematic
style and we wanted it to feel real it
was a monumental endeavor
you don't all people stand
they fool themselves
[Music]
[Music]
you